world champion Magnus Carlson curly one
and a half out of two Magnus I have to
ask you we're mystified here why doesn't
everybody play the vocal Indian and make
it look easy the way you did
uh obviously there are
uh there are many many good openings for
for black
um I guess I used to play this line
um many years ago I played it against
him in the candidates and and
um in 2013 and then I just I think I
made some weird move like A6 or
something instead of taking on C4 this
is supposed to be fairly harmless I feel
like there was sort of one interesting
moment in in the game
um where he um after Queen A5 he could
have gone for E4 yes
by Queen C4 yeah so exactly I mean I
thought like objectively the best was
Knight A4 and then go take my Bishop on
D7 and then you know like this Knight A4
yeah
and then I thought well okay Rook C3 but
I thought he would just chop chop it off
and like at least there's Bishop against
night I mean I guess it's nothing but
um I mean
after uh but the critical line was E4 or
at least the most forcing line and yeah
here I thought
um maybe Knight G4 but exactly B6 was
was the key basics in this position yeah
B6 was the key and then I thought I was
I was getting out so I was not
um and it didn't feel like I'd done
anything particularly wrong so it would
have felt pretty unfair if I was if I
was considerably worse there but it I
just thought for a bit just to realize
that B6 was was
um it was kind of okay there
um you don't feel that Levon is the one
that feels he didn't do anything wrong
and his wife didn't get absolutely
anything from the open no no but I mean
there are other ways to play for
instance you can block the check with
the Knights it's true on the way back in
before all right
but uh let me annotate that Bishop D2
inaccurate no no but I mean there are
there are deviations of course but I
think he
um he wasn't particularly aiming to to
to play very aggressively against the
line that I played I think he was like
seeing if we could get one or two
opportunities and when he didn't he just
steer the game towards the Drone in that
sense Quincy 4 is a very good move
um since it kind of forces my hand
um yeah if I don't if I play like Bishop
D7 then he has Knight E4 which is
at least some sort of moral victory for
for him so I have to go Knight E5 and
then yeah things are just getting
chopped off well we're going to ask you
a question since you finished so early
how do you evaluate this position in
particular we're thinking about this one
between Fabiano Carona and Lanier
Dominguez seems like Favi got his prep
in but he thought for a while before
deciding whether he wanted to take only
one and continue the game or play a move
like Knight F7 and Rook D6 how do you
make this kind of decisions over the
board no I I think
um he probably knows that both lines are
zeros and then he's trying to recall if
there are uh what the critical moves are
or and if there's any if there's any
risk involved in in playing rookie one
that's what I would guess but
my guess would be that he doesn't
remember
a lot from here just that it's supposed
to be supposed to be zeros and that
he's not risking too much well thank you
Magnus a job well done today with the
black pieces I don't like to think of it
that way how do you like to think of it
no it's just um you know I think nobody
really loves these games but
at this level they happen of course of
course they do happen once in a while
well Magnus good luck in the rest of
your games thank you indeed uh Magnus uh
good luck